deswegen kommen wir gleich zum nächsten
also bei einem letzten für heute sie
sehen hier schon die zuständige
ministerin für entwicklung und
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit svenja
schulze und es sind haushaltsberatungen
die nicht so sind wie in jedem jahr das
haben wir von sehr vielen abgeordneten
hier in dieser woche schon gehört es ist
eine tat mit unsicherheiten angesichts
der ukraine kriegs einen etat der ja
noch einen ergänzungs haushalt dann in
den parlamentarischen beratungen
bekommen soll und gerade hier die
ministerin die hat heute schon mal im
vorfeld dieser debatte angemerkt dass
sie wegen des ukraine kriegs doch mehr
notwendige hilfs ausgaben sieht und mehr
geld für ihr ministerium
fordert
sie kritisiert dass gerade ihre soll
nach den bisherigen plänen mit rund 10,8
milliarden euro auskommen soll das sind
zwölf prozent weniger als im vergangenen
jahr also da hören wir doch mal und das
wird doch einer
mutmaßlich interessante rede hier von
svenja schulze
ich eröffne die aussprache das wort hat
die bundesministerin svenja schulze
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
putins völkerrechtswidriger krieg der
verursacht unermessliches leid für die
menschen in der ukraine und die
bundesregierung hilft wo sie kann wir
wollen diesen krieg so schnell es geht
beenden und die lage für die menschen
verbessern aber derzeit um das wissen
sie wird die situation in der ukraine
von tag zu tag schlimmer menschen
starben durch russische angriffe und an
den folgen der zerstörung
nahrungsmittel wasser medikamente und
unterkünfte fehlen zehn millionen
menschen wurden aus ihren häusern
vertrieben ein teil von ihm sucht schutz
in der eu und in der republik moldau
doch die meisten die bleiben in der
ukraine sie sind vertriebene im eigenen
land und seit der völkerrechtswidrigen
annexion der krim durch putin im jahr
2014 unterstützt das
entwicklungsministerium die
binnenvertriebenen in der ukraine mit
dem bau von unterkünften und auch mit
sozial psychologischer betreuung unser
engagement hat sich ursprünglich mal auf
die ost ukraine fokussiert und jetzt
verlagert sich natürlich unsere akute
unterstützung auf das gesamte land
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat heute früh
an die bilder der zerstörten wohnungen
und viele frauen und kinder erinnert sie
verdeutlichen sehr sehr deutlich wir
werden das engagement jetzt massiv
ausbauen müssten ich halte das für ein
gebot der menschlichkeit
die kolleginnen und kollegen die folgen
des krieges sind darüber hinaus aber
jetzt schon weltweit spürbar der krieg
in der kornkammer der welt hat
dramatische auswirkungen auf die
weltweite ernährung schon jetzt liegen
die weltmarktpreise für getreide auf dem
historischen höchststand von 2008 jeder
weitere kriegstag führt nicht nur zu
mehr kriegstoten sondern auch zu mehr
hungertoten in der folge und deshalb
müssen wir jetzt alles dafür tun weitere
hungersnöte zu verhindern gemeinsam mit
unseren partnern fahren wir die
internationalen unterstützungsprogramme
sehr schnell hoch das
entwicklungsministerium handelt hier im
engen schulterschluss mit dem außen mit
dem landwirtschaftsministerium und ich
bin auch den vielen
zivilgesellschaftlichen organisationen
enorm dankbar die jetzt wirklich mit
großem engagement helfen uns allen ist
klar dass beispielsweise die im
regierungsentwurf eingeplant und 28
millionen euro für das
welternährungsprogramm nicht reichen
werden um ernteausfälle auszugleichen
und hungersnöte zu verhindern und ich
zähle auch sie dass wir hier noch einmal
nach legen können
[Applaus]
das ist eine ganz wichtige reaktion auf
die kurzfristigen schocks aber
wir wissen doch alle dass es dabei nicht
bleiben kann die agrar und
ernährungsmesse müssen grundsätzlich
verändert werden und daher möchte ich
mit unseren partnerländern die
investitionen in eine nachhaltige
widerstandsfähige landwirtschaft
ausbauen und sie wissen ein euro als
investition in krisenfeste
gesellschaften spart später vier euro an
humanitärer nothilfe diese
transformation ist also kein luxus den
wir nach der krise mal angehen können
sondern sie ist aktive krisenprävention
und darum ist es nur realistisch dass
die bundesregierung vom vorliegenden
haushalt lediglich von einem
zwischenstand spricht liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die herausforderungen für
die entwicklungszusammenarbeit waren
schon vor dem krieg enorm nehmen wir die
kurve 19 pandemie die größte
gesundheitskrise seit jahrzehnten gerade
für die ärmsten länder ist die zu einer
polit an dem mini geworden mit
gesundheitlichem aber auch mit
wirtschaftlichen mit sozialen folgen und
deswegen ist es gut und wichtig dass
deutschland auch in diesem jahr seinen
anteil am weltweiten einsatz gegen die
korona pandemie leisten wird so sieht es
der beschluss des kabinetts vor und das
wird hoffentlich auch der bundestag
unterstützen damit können wir einen
beitrag zum ende der pandemie und für
die resilienz der gesundheitssysteme
leisten zu dieser politik kommen aber
viele probleme hinzu und das ist auch
die klimakrise es ist vollkommen klar
die ärmsten länder der welt die sind
wenig bis gar nicht für den
menschengemachten klimawandel
verantwortlich zu drei trifft es aber
die angsten länder am härtesten die
klimakrise für zu dürren zu stürmen zu
überschwemmungen und dadurch werden auch
ernten werden beide und anbauflächen
zerstört
nahrungsmittelknappheit und steigende
preise sind wiederum die folge und auch
deshalb ist die bewältigung des
klimawandels und die klimaanpassung eine
ganz zentrales politikfeld für die
gesamte regierung und auch für das
entwicklungsministerium
ich habe erst vor kurzem mit dem
ruandischen finanzminister die juroren
des deutsche klima und entwicklungs
partnerschaft unterzeichnen können und
ich bin froh dass wir gemeinsam mit dem
g 7 staaten während unserer
präsidentschaft diese art von
partnerschaften weiter vorantreiben sie
und andere projekte aus meinem haus
leisten einen ganz wichtigen beitrag
damit das pariser klimaschutz abkommen
erfüllt werden kann und daher müssen
auch in zukunft ausreichend mittel zur
internationalen thema finanzierung zur
verfügung stehen
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
russische angriffskrieg wird die
multiplen krisen dieser welt noch weiter
verstärken wir erleben verschiedene
heftige krisen die sich überlagern und
die sich gegenseitig verstärken darunter
werden die länder des globalen südens
ganz besonders stark leiden regionale
konflikte werden wahrscheinlich noch
schwerer
einzuhegen sein das wird alles zu einer
herkulesaufgabe für die
entwicklungspolitik von der
ernährungssicherung über den
gesundheitsschutz die energie sicherheit
bis zu dem aufbau von infrastruktur für
menschen die ihr zuhause verlassen
mussten und es ist gut und wichtig das
haben wir gerade diskutiert dass die
bundeswehr künftig auskömmlich
finanziert wird aber zugleich hat nutze
nicht darauf hingewiesen erfolgreiche
sicherheitspolitik muss umfassend sein
neben einer gut ausgestatteten
bundeswehr braucht deutschland auch eine
starke entwicklungspolitik die künftigen
krisen vorbeugen und darum werde ich
mich innerhalb
regierung und auch im parlamentarischen
verfahren dafür einsetzen dass wir diese
aufgaben auch wahrnehmen können dabei 40
euro unterstützt
sagte die ministerin und schaut ins
parlament
zu ihrer eigenen fraktion zu den anderen
fraktionen
und hofft im parlamentarischen verfahren
noch
die cdu schlage für ihre suche zu
beginnen die aussprache jetzt mit
hermann gröhe für die cdu/csu-fraktion
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegin frau ministerin schulze sie
werben zu recht für eine starke politik
im bereich wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung ja dann
machen sie doch auch wir alle wissen
globale krisen treffen gerade die
ärmsten der armen das gilt für die
folgen des klimawandels die
nahrungsmittel anbauflächen gefährden ja
häufig zerstören das gilt für die folgen
der korona pandemie die uns beim kampf
gegen den welthunger zurückgeworfen
haben und vielerorts bildung von jungen
menschen gefährden und das gilt
schließlich auch für den krieg gegen die
ukraine natürlich leiden unter diesen
schrecklichen krieg vor allem die
menschen die in der keine selbst leben
aber seine globalen folgen gerade bei
der nahrungsmittelversorgung treffen
eben auch wieder in besonderer weise die
ärmsten der welt meine damen meine
herren der krieg gegen die ukraine mag
mehrbedarf ergründen etwa auch im
hinblick auf die nachbarschaft russlands
zb im kaukasus oder in zentralasien
er begründet keineswegs ihre
streichungen in einer zeit in der es
mehr globale solidarität braucht sinkt
der etat des bundesministeriums für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
und entwicklung und 1,57 milliarden euro
das zeigt eine völlig verfehlte
prioritätensetzung dieser regierung
und sie können uns keineswegs auf den
angekündigten nachtragshaushalt
verweisen denn viele viele ihrer
kürzungspläne lassen sich keineswegs
rückgängig machen unter hinweis auf den
krieg gegen die ukraine ja der ukraine
kriegt verschärft und darauf haben sie
zu recht hingewiesen
die hungerkrise russland und die ukraine
haben an der weltweiten versorgung mit
weizen den exporten einen anteil von 30
prozent bei meist von 20 prozent bei
sonnenblumenkernen als grundlage für
speise oder von 75 prozent gerade
nordafrika der nahe osten und
sub-sahara-afrika sind vom wegfall
dieser exporte dramatisch betroffen aber
schon vor dieser krise war allein durch
die folgen der pandemie corona pandemie
der kampf gegen den hunger in der welt
unter die mehr als 800 millionen
menschen bitter leiden deutlich
betroffen und was machen sie sie
reduzieren den kern beitrag für das
welternährungsprogramm um 40 prozent bei
der sonder initiative welt ohne hunger
streichen sie 60 millionen mehr als zehn
prozent so werden sie unserer
verantwortung nicht gerecht in einer
zeit in der vielerorts freiheits räume
für zivilgesellschaftliche aktivitäten
beschnitten werden die internationale
debatte findet unter dem schlagwort
shrinking space statt kürzen sie die
mittel für die entwicklungspolitische
vorhaben der kirchen und heyer träger
obwohl gerade deren partnerschaften
häufig für bedrängte
zivilgesellschaftliche akteure eine
wichtige schutzfunktion
entfalte und zu allem überfluss
kürzen sie die förderung freier medien
um 25 prozent in einer zeit in der
weltweit krisen sich zuspitzen senken
sie die mittel für krisenbewältigung und
wiederaufbau und 380 millionen euro das
sind sage und schreibe 40 prozent 40
prozent sieht bei ihnen eigentlich
keiner mehr nachrichten meine damen
meine herren das doch unglaublich in
einer zeit in der wir gemeinsam wert
darauf legen dass verantwortlich
gestaltete lieferketten wichtig sind und
wir deswegen die wirtschaft mit einem
lieferketten gesetz in die pflicht
nehmen und ich habe mich stets dazu
bekannt kürzen sie im bereich der
entwicklungspartnerschaft mit der
wirtschaft über 70 millionen euro mehr
als 25 prozent andere in die pflicht
nehmen aber sich selber aus der
verantwortung stehlen das passt nicht
zusammen meine damen meine herren weil
der bilateralen finanziellen
zusammenarbeit einem kernstück unserer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit kürzen sie
rund 350 millionen euro fast 15 prozent
und schließlich sei auch noch einmal auf
das thema globale gesundheit hingewiesen
ich will ausdrücklich begrüßen dass die
bundesregierung im rahmen der g7
präsidentschaft hier nachgeholt hat was
im koalitionsvertrag unterblieben ist
sich zu dieser führungsrolle zu bekennen
ich begrüße ausdrücklich dass im
einzelplan 60 über eine milliarde euro
vorgesehen sind für die weltweite
verteilung von impfstoff in den
entwicklungsländern das will ich
ausdrücklich unterstreichen aber wenn
wir aus der pandemie etwas lernen dann
geht es eben auch um die stärkung von
gesundheitssystemen vor ort und wenn sie
die mittel für den globalen fonds zur
bekämpfung von aids malaria und
tuberkulose zusammen streichen
in der jetzigen förderperiode eine
milliarde aus dem bundeshaushalt von
ihnen zukünftig vorgesehen 630 millionen
dann wird auch das unserer
vorbildfunktion in der welt nicht
gerecht meine damen und das kann man
zwar flex später reparieren im vollzug
aber jetzt werden doch die weichen auch
für die zusagen anderer gestellt es wird
sie nicht wundern dass die
nichtregierungsorganisation ihren
haushalt klar beurteilen völlig
unverständliche entscheidungen sagt brot
für die welt wenn der dachverband sagt
die kürzung kämen zum denkbar
schlechtesten zeitpunkt bliebe es dabei
so sei dies wörtlich eine schande ihr
haushalt bleibt hinter jedem eigenen
anspruch zurück aber schlimmer ist der
fehlstart der ampel in der
entwicklungspolitik gefährdet die
verantwortung unseres landes für die
globale entwicklung wir als union finden
uns damit nicht ab
sagte hermann gröhe der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu
fraktion hat den finger in die wunde
gelegt die kürzung im einzelplan 23 für
den entwicklungsetat
gefallen auch nicht jedem in der
ampelkoalition
deswegen sind wir mal gespannt auf die
weitere aussprache und hören mal was die
grünen dazu zu sagen haben sie mich
jeder nächsten sich die
frau präsidentin com ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen am 18 januar
1977 verdoppelten sich in ägypten von
einem tag auf den anderen die preise für
brot mehl und zucker und andere
grundnahrungsmittel
tags zuvor hatte der damalige ägyptische
präsident anwar as sadat die staatlichen
subventionen gestrichen tags darauf kam
es zu protesten sechs bis neun millionen
menschen gingen auf die straße etwa 100
bezahlten mit ihrem leben
diese blutigen tage sind in ägyptische
geschichte als die sogenannten blut
geboten eingegangen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen diese brotunruhen sind nur
eins von vielen beispielen in der
geschichte und nicht mal das
dramatischste dafür wie am beginn von
leid und konflikt die sorge vor hunger
und vor mangel stehen und wenn wir in
diesen schaden über die auswirkungen des
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffs auf die
ukraine auf die weltweite sicherheit
sprechen dann dürfen wir nicht den
fehler machen unser verständnis von
sicherheit zu verkürzen und zu begrenzen
sicherheit ist offensichtlich mehr als
militärische stärke
und deswegen werden hier und es ist
wichtig die bundeswehr besser ausrüsten
aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass wir
gleichzeitig auch unseren kampf gegen
hunger und armut entsprechend finanziell
auch fortführen müssen denn jeder euro
den wir in stabilisierenden präventive
maßnahmen zivile krisenprävention
unterstützung der zivilgesellschaft in
fragilen ländern und vieles mehr stecken
jeder euro verringert die gefahr für
kriegerische und blutige
auseinandersetzungen in der zukunft und
meine damen und herren die
korona pandemie die globale pandemie hat
auf die globalen ungleichheiten und
bunten richtigkeit noch mal verstärkend
gewirkt
noch die zahl der menschen die unter
extremer armut leiden ist so groß wie in
den letzten jahren nicht steigt wieder
frauen und mädchen sind besonders
betroffen die klimakrise die globale
erderwärmung trifft viele regionen jetzt
schon dramatisch
die krisen sind viele die lage ist ernst
die herausfanden sind groß und sie
werden größer und ja in dieser situation
ist eine streichung von 1 06 milliarden
euro im haushalt gegenüber dem letzten
jahr das falsche signal und deswegen
gleich zu ihm und deswegen werden wir
auch im wenn wir jetzt über den
ergänzungs haushalt sprechen darauf
hinwirken dass dieser der ja die folgen
des krieges in der ukraine abbilden soll
eben auch die globalen folgen und damit
auch diesen etat abhängen wird aber herr
gröhe
ich kann mich noch sehr gut erinnern
auch an die debatte die wir hier vor ein
paar wochen geführt haben zum
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung da war ja viel tumult ja
viel aufregung hochrote köpfe und darin
mein kollege jan gegners lesen wo es
auch damals schon vorgerechnet dass es
ja schon der finanzplan der großen
koalition unter führung der union war
der genau diese reduktion vorgesehen hat
der ein sinkendes plattform vorgesehen
und ich war wir sind ja gleich dran hält
dr stefan ich war auch
ja sie sind gleichrangig war auch
gestern anwesend als herr dobrindt
gesprochen hat und ich leuten morgen
anwesend als der märz gesprochen hat
schlecht tauschen sie mal die nummern
unter anderem aus sie scheinen der
nämlich ein paar diskussions
vorsichtiger wenn herr dobrindt sagt der
verteidigungshaushalt müsse allein
eigentlich aus mitteln des kern
haushaltes anwachsen dann müsse eben
woanders gespart werden dann würde
zwingend hier noch stärker gespart
werden und deshalb ist es unehrlich was
sie hier aufführen wenn sie dafür sorgen
wollen wenn sie dafür sorgen wollen dass
hier meter ansteigt haben sie uns auch
ihrer seite aber da macht es überall und
auch in der fraktionsspitze
meine damen und herren ich will deswegen
zu zum ende drei punkte hervorheben die
für uns und für mich wichtig sind
erstens 0,7 prozent dieses haushaltes
gehen der des bruttonationaleinkommens
gehen in entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
humanitäre hilfe das oder ziel von 0,7
prozent wird auch erfüllt und unter hand
haben deswegen meine damen und herren
von union weil gegenüber dem entwurf der
vordere regierung noch um eine milliarde
drauf gesetzt wurde das ist das was wir
wollen das ist auch das was wir den
nächsten jahren wollen dafür werden wir
es einsetzen dass dieses niveau gehalten
wird zweitens wir werden morgen noch
viel über klimaschutz sprechen in dieser
situation muss uns allen klar sein dass
wir insbesondere für den globalen
klimaschutz und für die internationale
klimafinanzierung mehr tun müssen dass
wir das oft gute finanzielle basis
stellen müssen dass wir energie
partnerschaft auf augenhöhe stärken
müssen dass es eine priorität dieser
koalition und als letztes will ich nach
zwölf jahren
dirk niebel und gerd müller an der
hausspitze 1 noch bemerken es gibt keine
globale gerechtigkeit ohne
geschlechtergerechtigkeit die krisen von
denen wir gesprochen haben sie treffen
frauen und mädchen besonders stark
eingriffe in die reproduktive in die
reproduktiven rechte
zwangsverheiratungen und vieles mehr
alle tassen im zug und unsere antworten
jetzt ist recht wahrscheinlich
unangenehmen dort ganz rechts außen ist
eine feministische außen- sicherheits-
und entwicklungspolitik da haben wir uns
an ihrer seite frauen drin so wie sie
uns immer an ihrer seite haben wenn die
güte prioritäten setzen und da wo das
vielleicht noch nicht ganz der fall ist
helfen wir im haushaltsverfahren gerne
nach ich freue mich darauf vielen dank
und das hört doch die entwicklungs
ministerin gerne und sie hat ja auch das
angekündigt was hier felix magath noch
mal genannt hat nämlich auch eine
feministische
entwicklungspolitik gleichstellung sei
auch ein schlüssel für das erreichen der
ziele
armut und hunger
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen liebe zuschauer im
saal und bei youtube die regierung
schreibt in ihrem etat entwurf zum
einzelplan 23 für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung ich
zitiere die deutsche entwicklungspolitik
befasst sich mit den zentralen
überlebens und zukunftsfragen der
menschheit der gesamten menschheit frau
ministerin ein bisschen kleiner ging es
dann wohl offensichtlich nicht doch
dieser satz ist ein weiterer beleg für
meine these von heute mittag das auch
die deutsche außenpolitik dazu
beigetragen hat dass die westliche
wertegemeinschaft in einigen teilen der
welt als arrogant und ignorant
wahrgenommen wird denn bei einer
nüchternen betrachtung des konzepts
entwicklungshilfe und ihrer sogenannten
erfolge landet man tatsächlich sehr
schnell bei dem wort ignoranz seit
jahren werden millionen milliarden sogar
millionen weltweit für die
entwicklungshilfe ausgegeben und noch
immer präsentieren sich die
krisenregionen der welt als
krisenregionen noch immer herrscht immer
gesundheitliche unterversorgung
korruption und gewalt in großen teilen
der welt und wirklich entwickelt wurde
in vielen fällen nur solange etwas wie
die jeweiligen projekte finanziert
wurden und dennoch hat sich das
entwicklungshilfe system trotz
offenkundiger ineffizienz kaum verändert
man muss sich die frage stellen wollen
nicht dass jetzt gibt sicherlich jemand
der sofort fordert mehr geld doch das
sehen die betroffenen ganz anders denn
durch entwicklungshilfegelder ist ein
system von dauerhaften abhängigkeiten
geschaffen worden in dem die
eigeninitiative häufig verkümmert und
man obendrein de facto noch korrupte
regierung unterstützt die es mit den
menschenrechten und ohnehin nicht so
genau nehmen vertreter von sogenannten
nehmerländern wollen aus diesem
kreislauf ausbrechen sie wollen nicht
mehr als opfer und empfänger milder
gaben gelten sondern ihr leben und ihr
land selbstbestimmt gestalten deshalb
deshalb setzen sie auf eine verbesserung
ihrer wirtschaftlichen beziehungen und
auf den internationalen handel was gut
ist doch genau hier stehen viele gelber
geberländern nun im weg die an ihren
handelsbeschränkungen und marktzutritts
barrieren frist halten auch deutschland
ist hier leider keine ausnahme und mehr
noch die gewährung von
entwicklungshilfegeldern wird immer ein
einhaltung von vorgegebenen standards
gekoppelt denn man will ja gleichzeitig
zieht ihre frieden fördern und
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit
korruptionsbekämpfung und gute
regierungsführung stärken zitat ende ich
bin der größte verfechter dieser werte
aber man muss einfach verstehen wie
anmaßend und beleidigend für andere
staaten und völker es ist in westliche
länder daher kommen und sich in diese
politik der länder einmischen
man muss sich das mal vorstellen die
deutsche entwicklungspolitik geht hin
und will in anderen ländern gute
regierungsführung stärken das kommt
einfach verdammt schlecht an und so
verwundert es auch nicht wenn sich die
nehmerländer der welt mit steigender
tendenz china zu widmen denn die
menschen diesen ländern haben die
belehrungen einmischungen das mitleid
des westens satt sie wollen die
gleichberechtigte partner behandelt
werden was übrigens auch nicht
verwundert wenn man sich mal anguckt mit
was für stolze völker man es hier zu tun
hat selbstverständlich wünschen sie sich
auch dort ein system entwickelt er
demokratie wie wir es kennen mit
westlichen freiheiten mit
rechtsstaatlichkeit und menschenwürde
wer würde das nicht aber man muss
verstehen dass der versuch diese werte
quasi von oben völlig andersartigen
kulturen aufzuzwingen scheitern muss und
in der vergangenheit auch immer wieder
gescheitert ist
in dem deutschland an diesem versuch
wider besseren wissens festhält
scheitert unser land damit nicht nur an
einer effizienten hilfe sondern auch am
punkt wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
viele der nehmerländer beherbergen
nämlich große rohstoffvorkommen die
sämtliche industrienationen für die
produktion und den wohlstand brauchen
und natürlich hat china sich hier an
bereits einen großen anteil gesichert
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
unsere weltordnung verändert sich gerade
und wir befürchten dass sich deutschland
international zunehmend türen schließen
werten wenn wir so weitermachen wie
bisher und das wird für unser volk und
für unsere wirtschaft nicht besonders
gut sein aber ich sage ihnen auch dass
das nicht so sein muss deutschland wird
noch immer respektiert international und
wenn wir uns von alten vorstellungen
emanzipieren und mit respekt und auf
augenhöhe auf andere länder zu gehen
dann können wir die zeiten auch wieder
besser und stabiler gestalten wir haben
es in der hand danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
es spricht die arabischen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich bin
volkswirtin und dozenten als solche
beschäftige ich mich schon lange mit
öffentlichen haushalten das hier war
einmal hier im bundestag eine rede zur
haushaltsdebatte halten würde hätte ich
nie erwartet als politische
quereinsteigerin bin ich vor allem aus
einem grund angetreten ich habe meinen
drei kindern die schon großen aus dem
gröbsten raus sind versprochen mich für
ihre generation einzusetzen das ist die
generation die unsere generation der
geburtenstarken jahrgänge in den
kommenden jahren ablösen wird
und ich will daran mitarbeiten dass wir
ihnen nicht einen haufen schulden und
offene baustellen überlassen sondern ein
lebenswertes land ein funktionierendes
land mit stabilen
staatsfinanzen
kommen wir nun zum einzelplan 23 für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung es geht hier um länder den
wir auf dem weg zu mehr stabilität
wohlstand und rechtsstaatlichkeit unsere
hilfe versprochen haben auch im namen
der zukünftigen generationen die genauso
wie wir an einem friedvollen miteinander
der entwickelten und sich entwickelnden
länder interessiert sein müssen dass
entwicklungszusammenarbeit einen sehr
langen atem braucht dass ihre erfolge
nicht immer akkurat messbar sind und
dass sie oft fragil bleiben das alles
ist nicht nur seit der korona pandemie
hat sich diese erkenntnis aber nochmals
verschärft die globalen probleme sind
noch größer geworden viele erfolge der
vergangenheit sind bedroht oder zunichte
gemacht und die weiteren
herausforderungen kommt können einem
ehrlich gesagt den a proben
dennoch waren wir zu beginn des jahres
so weit optimistisch gestimmt dass die
pandemie zumindest einen teil ihres
schreckens verloren hatte und dass
vielerorts sogar ein rica wetter möglich
sein könnte all dies ist ihm von der
geschichte überholt worden denn gerade
als wir dachten nach der pandemie
könnte so schnell nichts schlimmeres
kommen hat putin uns mit seinem angriff
auf die ukraine eines besseren belehrt
zusätzlich zu allen anderen krisenherden
und zusätzlich zu den pandemie folgen
müssen wir nun folgen eines krieges
bewältigen der uns geografisch nicht nur
direkt betrifft sondern ganz konkret in
form geflüchteter von frauen und ihre
kinder die bei uns schon
wieder gibt es als rückschläge für die
wirtschaft die wir im übrigen so
dringend brauchen um den wiederaufbau
nach krieg und fuhr ohne zu stemmen und
wieder kommt mit osteuropa ein neuer
schwerpunkt in sachen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit auf uns zu
für viele länder vor allem in afrika
bedeutet der krieg das durch
ernteausfälle der kornkammer viel
weniger getreide zur verfügung stellt
neue oder sich verschärfen der
hungersnöte sind vorprogrammiert
es ist daher absolut richtig dass wir im
regierungsentwurf über zehn milliarden
euro für den einzelplan 23 vorsehen alle
ausgaben in diesem bereich sind
investitionen in eine stabilere
menschenfreundlichere zukunft
auch wenn es für den einen oder die
andere jetzt paradox wirken mag gerade
weil die ausgang so wichtig und
zukunftssicher und sind müssen wir hier
mit besonders kühlen kopf gehen nur wenn
wir absolut solide wirtschaften haben
wir eine chance die schier
überwältigende menge an aufgaben angehen
zu können darum gehört für mich alles
auf den prüfstand es darf kein
festhalten an strukturen aus reiner
gewohnheit geben egal ob es um kleine
oder große organisation und bi oder
multilaterale projekte geht eine der oft
wiederholten lehrer aus der pandemie
lautet dass wir schneller werden müssten
digitaler vernetzter und sehr viel
schlanker das wünsche ich mir nicht nur
für deutsche unter un-verwaltung das
wünsche ich mir auch im umgang mit
haushaltsmitteln in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit macht die
globalität die dinge zwar oft komplexer
aber in satten best practice und
vernetzten denkens bietet sie zugleich
enorme chancen wenn ich also das
versprechen
wenn ich also das versprechen einhalten
will dass ich meinen kindern gegeben
habe kann die lösung nicht sein einfach
nur immer mehr zu fordern mehr projekte
zu starten mehr gelder bereitzustellen
ich denke die lösung liegt darin dass
wir effizienter werden wir brauchen mehr
qualitätskontrolle aber sicher nicht
mehr verwaltung um die oder
um die oda quote zu erfüllen brauchen
wir ansätze in mehreren einzelplänen
aber keine doppelstrukturen und
kompetenzgerangel wenn wir die
schuldenbremse ab 2023 wieder einhalten
wollen müssen wir nicht einfach nur
sparen sondern
wirklich klug mit unseren mitteln
umgehen und aus jedem investierten euro
das maximale ergebnis herausholen denn
nur wenn wir schnell zu einer soliden
haushaltsführung zurückkommen kann
deutschland langfristig eines der
größten geberländer in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit bleibt
es war ihre erste rede und ich hatte
glück wünschen wir sie
und glücklicherweise gibt es da applaus
aus allen fraktionen hier
sogar von den meisten fraktionen claudia
füssen ist für die fdp bei die
landesliste baden württemberg hier in
den deutschen bundestag eingezogen
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren frau ministerin ich glaube
wir können nur ansatzweise die folgen
abschätzen zurzeit die der
völkerrechtswidrige angriffskrieg
russlands auf die heine beinhaltet
natürlich
leiden zuallererst die menschen in der
ukraine in den städten die bombardiert
werden die flüchtlinge dort aber auch
hierzulande die ernsten von den
gehsteigen gestiegenen energiepreisen
wenn nicht gegen gehandelt wird auch in
russland ein teil der bevölkerung wird
leiden aber insbesondere
leiden diejenigen teile auch der
weltbevölkerung die von den getreide
exporten aus russland und der ukraine
abhängig sind und all das ist einer der
gründe warum dieser krieg so schnell wie
möglich beendet werden muss und alles
getan werden muss dass dieser krieg
endet
box fahren etwa sagt dass in
nordostafrika
das ostafrika 90 prozent des weizens aus
russland und der ukraine
importiert laut dem chef des deutschen
instituts für wirtschaftsforschung
würden bis zu über 100 millionen
menschen zusätzlich in hunger getrieben
durch die folgen des krieges der
sanktionen und gegen sanktionen des
import des exportstopps zb in russland
von weizen und wahrscheinlich auch von
kali
all das wie gesagt ein grund dass dieser
krieg beendet werden muss aber in dieser
situation frau ministerin das muss ich
schon sagen in dieser situation auch
angesichts der anderen krisen der
pandemie
der schreienden sozialen ungleichheit
weltweit
in dieser situation den entwicklungsetat
um knapp 13 prozent zu kürzen
das ist völlig unverständlich und das
lehnen wir ab und das ist herr gröhe hat
ja im detail darauf hingewiesen in
welchen bereichen hier gekürzt wird aber
es kontrastiert eben auch völlig dass
auf der anderen seite 100 milliarden
euro für einen sonderfonds zur
aufrüstung auch noch ins grundgesetz
verankert hier beschlossen werden sollen
das sind alles völlig falsche
prioritäten setzen
wir fordern mit blick auf die
entwicklungspolitik eine klare priorität
auf zivile mittel der krisenprävention
jeder euro das wurde hier schon gesagt
der hier investiert wird ist auch eine
investition in die sicherheit und
vielleicht die abwehr von günstigen
konflikten und krisen wir fordern keine
absenkung der mittel für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit von was jetzt
vorgesehen ist 1,6 milliarden euro wie
es die ampel jetzt in dem
haushaltsentwurf vorsieht
stattdessen einen konstanten aufwuchs
der mittel für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit über die
kommenden jahre bis zum ende der
legislatur um das 0,7 prozent ziel
dauerhaft und stabil auch zu halten dass
die
oecd-länder sich gegenseitig versprochen
haben geht ja sogar länder die sogar
über ein sind hier will ich auch mal
dran erinnern
wir fordern eine aufstockung der
globalen klima mittel aber eben
zusätzlich zum entwicklungs haushalt und
nicht sozusagen mit dem dann verrechnet
wir fordern die sofortige erfüllung des
oecd ziels mindestens 0,2 prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts für die
allerärmsten länder zur verfügung zu
stellen und die sofortige erfüllung des
ziels
0,1 prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukt für
die gesundheitsbezogene
entwicklungszusammenarbeit zur verfügung
zu stellen und hier mit weltweit den
ausbau einer qualitativ hochwertigen
basis gesundheitsinfrastruktur zu der
alle menschen zugang haben müssen zu
unterstützen
dafür schlagen wir einen globalen fonds
für die universelle
gesundheitsversorgung vor des weiteren
eine sofortige entschuldigung der
allerärmsten länder des südens das ist
ja schon eine ganz lange diskussion und
zu guter letzt einen klaren fokus der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit auf den abbau
von abhängigkeiten und hier insbesondere
im bereich der ernährungssicherung und
zwar durch die förderung von
ernährungssouveränität in den ländern
des südens vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
andrej hunko war das für die linke
hier in der aussprache zum einzelplan
entwicklung und natürlich hat er auch
hier die umfangreiche kritik seiner
fraktion formuliert jetzt hören wir für
die spd gabriele heinrich gabriela
verzeigung heinrich stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren wer die bilder von
mario pohl in den nachrichten sieht der
bekommt eine ahnung von großem leid in
der ukraine
die russische armee zabold häuser sie
tötet und verletzt zivilisten sie macht
städte dem erdboden gleich hier um die
ecke am hauptbahnhof sehen wir die
auswirkungen von putins krieg hier
kommen frauen und kinder an sie sind im
krieg entkommen aber wenn wir in ihre
gesichter schauen bekommen wir eine
ahnung von dem was ja tragen muss
wir werden uns noch sehr lange
hoffentlich um ein wiederaufbau in der
ukraine kümmern müssen
wir können dieses leid nicht vergleichen
mit den auswirkungen des kriegs in
deutschland aber auch die menschen bei
uns sind massiv von steigenden preisen
für energie und lebensmittel betroffen
rohstoffe sind knapper und lieferketten
unterbrochen und wir beschäftigen uns
hier in allen bereichen mit diesen
auswirkungen
wie viel mehr aber betrifft der krieg in
seinem ausmaß die länder des globalen
südens
die ministerin hatte schon gesagt woher
kommen denn die getreideimporte der
entwicklungsländer woher kommen die
lieferung des world food programms die
ukraine und russland
waren ford putins krieg kornkammern für
einen großteil der welt und insbesondere
des globalen auch länder wie marokko und
tunesien
leiden unter steigenden bodenpreisen und
die möglichen folgen für die stabilität
vieler länder können wir uns durchaus
vorstellen
putins krieg wird hunger und elend weit
entfernt von der ukraine verursachen
eine priorität unserer internationalen
zusammenarbeit muss es sein den menschen
zu helfen die aktuell nicht im fokus
unserer aufmerksamkeit stehen und dabei
gilt auch sowie deutschland unabhängig
von russischer energie werden muss so
müssen länder des globalen südens in die
lage versetzt werden unabhängig von
lebensmittelimporten zu werden und dabei
unterstützen wir sie mit unserer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und wollen
dies auch weiterhin massiv tun
durch den klimawandel haben dürfen
fluten und missernten insbesondere im
globalen süden bereits dramatisch
zugenommen die versorgungslage ist
vielerorts prekär
hilfe bei der anpassung der produktion
an neue klimatische
realitäten und herausforderungen wird
dringend benötigt diese hilfe lindert
den hunger und begleitet den übergang
von der krise zur stabilität die
förderung lokale landwirtschaften
anzupassen muss ein eckpfeiler unseres
engagement sein dazu gehören klima
partnerschaften ebenso wie die
unterstützung beim aufbau einer eigenen
impfstoff produktion
wir können und wir dürfen deshalb nicht
sparen im gegenteil mittel für den
einzelplan 23 sind wohl investiertes
geld im interesse der partnerländer im
interesse der multilateralen
zusammenarbeit und in unserem ureigenen
interesse
an dieser neuen krise müssen wir die
bedarfe des bmz und damit das einzel
plans 23 neu beurteilen und wo nötig
anpassen alle demokratischen
entwicklungs politikerinnen sind sich
einig dass jetzt auf der grundlage von
sehr realen und existenziellen bedarfen
geplant nach gesteuert und entsprechend
finanziert werden muss
und kollege gröhe
sie sind ein aufrechter
entwicklungspolitiker das weiß ich wohl
aber auch sie müssen dass es nicht
unsere entwicklungsministerin war die
die ersten 100 tage dazu genutzt hat
überall den kürzungs stift anzusetzen
sondern dass wir
gemeinsam für 20 und 21 einen sehr viel
höheren haushaltsplan aufgestellt haben
unter anderem wegen kobe und wir hatten
die offensichtlich falsche hoffnung dass
diese krise
bereits vorbei sein wird und wir müssen
heute feststellen dieser krise ist eine
weitere noch globalere krise dazu
gekommen und deshalb können wir und
wollen wir es so nicht stehen lassen und
hoffen auf ihre unterstützung
meine damen und herren der krieg in der
ukraine ist auch ein konflikt zwischen
demokratie und autokratie zwischen
freiheit und diktatur freiheitliche
gesellschaften demokratie und
menschenrechtsaktivisten und die
meinungsfreiheit sind fast weltweit
unter druck
autoritäre regime erfahren immer
massivere des informationskampagnen
diese sollen die zivilgesellschaft
balken und sie sollen sie schwächen
deshalb muss unsere
entwicklungszusammenarbeit auch unsere
werte deutlich machen und unterstützen
die förderung von demokratie und
zivilgesellschaft muss und pfeiler
unserer arbeit bleiben
und übrigens
bundesministerin svenja schulze nimmt
auch endlich die frauen in den fokus
ihrer
entwicklungspolitik wer da wohl das
spottet hat keine ahnung von
entwicklungspolitik
vorstellung davon wie entscheiden sich
entwicklungsländer wirtschaftlich und
gesellschaftlich verändern wenn frauen
entsprechend beteiligt sind frauen
halten die familien zusammen frauen
halten die gesellschaft zusammen deshalb
wer die feministische
entwicklungspolitik und übrigens frau
kollegin für minister außenpolitik
verlacht der verdacht die leistung von
frauen weltweit
[Applaus]
sagt gabriele heinrich für die spd
fraktion
und hat auch ihre sicht noch mal darauf
hingewiesen
dass der entwicklung des etat
nochmal verändert werden muss in den
beratungen
die anstehen in den nächsten wochen sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen frau ministerin
ich hatte in meiner letzten rede zum
entwicklungspolitischen bericht schon
darauf hingewiesen dass der
entwicklungsetat in den letzten 16
jahren unter angela merkel sich
verdreifacht verdreifacht hat und in der
amtszeit von gerd müller verdoppelt und
ich hatte ihnen in der letzten debatte
gesagt dass sie meinen respekt haben
wenn ihnen ähnliches gelingt und ich
stelle heute fest 16 jahre unions
regierung anwachsen des etats 100 tage
ampel kürzung um minus 12,6 prozent
das habe
dass liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist
eine schallende ohrfeige für unsere
partnerländer und sie senden ein fatales
signal in diese
krisengeschüttelte welt
viele nennen das auch begründen thema
menschenrechte bei allen besuchen in den
ländern bei allen programmen und
projekten fordern wir zu recht zu recht
die einhaltung von menschenrechten
unserer partnerländer ein bevor ein
rechtsstaatlichkeit unabhängige justiz
und demokratie und ich frage sie jetzt
allen ernstes von der ampel was erzählen
sie den unseren partnern nachdem
hofknicks von minister habeck in katar
einem land das bekanntlich kein
vorzeigeland ist beim thema
menschenrechte und gute
arbeitsbedingungen wie wollen sie dieses
thema weiterhin glaubwürdig vertreten
aber
was mich wirklich was mich wirklich
ärgert frau ministerin dass sie kein
einziges wort verlieren kein einziges
wort das man auch mit katar eine
wasserstoff kooperation eingegangen wird
und ich frage sie was ist mit afrika was
ist mit den begonnenen
energiepartnerschaft mit marokko mit
tunesien was ist mit der
weiterentwicklung der wasserstoff
strategie der partnerschaften mit den
ländern afrikas wann wenn nicht jetzt
frau ministerin wann wenn nicht jetzt
hätten sie ein signal nach afrika senden
können ein signal der vertieften
zusammenarbeit ein signal der
kooperation ein signal an die
staatschefs dass sich reformen lohnen
für hausfrau ministerin ihr haus heißt
auch wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
davon hört man von ihnen nicht nur eines
ein blick in den haushalt mittel werden
gekürzt ich erwarte eine antwort von
ihnen wie sie eigentlich neue jobs auf
dem afrikanischen kontinent fördern und
unterstützen wollen ohne
wirtschaftskooperationen ohne
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit afrika
braucht 20 millionen jobs pro jahr und
ich höre von ihnen nichts wie setzen sie
den marshall-plan mit afrika und wie
wollen sie die deutsche wirtschaft
unterstützen in afrika zu investieren
und ich frage sie haben sie minister
habe darauf hingewiesen dass wir eine
hervorragende ausgangslage bei den
energie partnerschaft mit afrikanischen
ländern haben dass es eine win win
situation wäre auf afrika hier zuzugehen
wachstum in den ländern für jobs und
wohlstand und gleichzeitig energie für
deutschland und europa aber interessant
wird ja auch werden die neue
freundschaft der grünen mit katar beim
thema feministische außen und
entwicklungspolitik
ich habe im übrigen in ihrem haushalt
keinen ansatz dafür gefunden für die
feministische
entwicklungspolitik vielleicht zeigen
sie mir mal den titel weil ansonsten war
es nur heiße luft eine schlagzeile ein
schaufenster thema und am ende sogar
noch etikettenschwindel aber
es stellt sich die grundsätzliche frage
ob sie ihren koalitionsvertrag nicht neu
verhandeln müssen sie schreiben in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag dass sie sich für eine
nachhaltige entwicklung und den kampf
gegen hunger einsetzen und gegen armut
natürlich klimagerechtigkeit
biodiversität alles hehre ziele die
wahrheit ist sie kürzen die mittel für
das welternährungsprogramm um 56 prozent
zu kürzen das sonderprogramm eine welt
ohne hunger um 60 millionen euro ja
meine damen und herren wir steuern auf
die größte hungersnot seit jahren zu und
sie kämpfen die mittel für
hungerbekämpfung der chef des world food
programms hat dieser tage gesagt ich
muss entscheiden ob ich die kinder in
der ukraine im jemen oder in äthiopien
hungern lassen weil das geld dafür nicht
reicht das ist ihre politik gleichzeitig
kürzen sie die mittel zur stabilisierung
für nordafrika um über 20 millionen euro
also genau diese staaten die von den
ausbleibenden weizen lieferungen am
meisten betroffen sind frau ministerin
es reicht nicht hier schöne reden zu
halten heiße luft zu produzieren heute
auch wieder schlagzeilen sie warnen vor
der hungersnot ich sage ihnen was waren
sie nicht handeln sie sie treiben in die
candy chinas wenn sie so weiter machen
aber
ich frage mich ja ohnehin wie die
außenpolitische rolle dieser regierung
ist und offenbar sollten die kollegen
der fdp recht behalten die in der
haushaltsdebatte 2020 gesagt haben ich
zitiere wenn olaf scholz kanzler wird
rutscht deutschland in die
internationale bedeutungslosigkeit ab
zitat ende ja so ist es offenbar aber
die fdp macht mit bravo herzlichen
glückwunsch
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lesen wir weiter im koalitionsvertrag
her ist er ein spannendes märchenbuch
wenn wir uns hier anschauen wir fördern
die zivilgesellschaft die gewerkschaften
die politischen und privaten stiftungen
und die kirchen die wahrheit ist sie
kürzen bei den medien stichwort
pressefreiheit zehn millionen zu kürzen
bei den politischen stiftungen stichwort
demokratie bildung vor ort rückgang um
15 millionen euro sie kürzen bei der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit der kirchen
brot für die welt misereor etc rückgang
um 20 millionen euro glaubwürdigkeit
sieht anders aus aber
bei einem punkt kürzen sie nicht wenn es
um die versorgung von genossen geht 20
neue hoch dotierte stellen im
ministerium mehrere millionen pro jahr
pensionsrückstellungen nicht
mitgerechnet hier wird nicht gekürzt
frau ministerin sie haben mit christian
lindner schlecht verhandelt und die
haushaltspolitik dieser regierung ist
eines sie ist unsolide und durchsichtig
und hat mit nachhaltiger finanzplanung
nichts zu tun sie wird vor allem der
rolle deutschlands in keinster weise
gerecht sie halten die versprechen nicht
einzulassen den globalen süden im stich
ich sage ihnen hören sie auf mit dieser
schaufensterpolitik und
solidaritätsbekundungen
hören sie auf mit warmen worten und
warnungen handeln sie endlich
sie haben das un welternährungsprogramm
ist schon mehrfach ihren der debatte
angesprochen worden
dessen chef beklagt eine starke
unterfinanzierung der
nahrungsmittelhilfe weltweit
man habe neun milliarden dollar weniger
als man brauche die monatlichen kosten
79 millionen dollar gestiegen weil die
preise eben für treibstoff transport und
lebensmittel nicht zuletzt weizen der
auf dem weltmarkt fehlt und bald noch
mehr fehlen wird gestiegen sein dass die
kolleginnen der moratorium für bündnis
90 die grünen die sprecherin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung bmz krone
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich werde jetzt in die debatte debatte
nicht schönreden der bmz etat sinkt um
1,6 milliarden euro das ist angesichts
der vielzahl an globalen
herausforderungen krisen einfach nicht
angemessen zu ihnen komme ich später
noch allein im ersten quartal 20 22
wurden 13 millionen menschen in
äthiopien kenia und somalia
auf der suche nach wasser und weideland
vertrieben die klimakrise kostet schon
jetzt millionen menschen ihr zuhause und
ernten fallen wegen ihr aus
gleichzeitig haben wir eine pandemie an
der nicht nur über sechs millionen
menschen gestorben sind sondern die auch
massiv zu sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
verwerfungen besonders im globalen süden
geführt hat als folge der korona
pandemie sind noch mal weitere
150 millionen menschen in absoluter
armut gefallen die klimakrise und die
anhaltende polizei verschärfen den
hunger in der welt in kenia ist die
ernte aufgrund der dürfen des letzten
jahres um 70 prozent zurückgegangen das
land hat den nationalen
katastrophenzustand ausgerufen mehr als
ein zehntel der weltbevölkerung hungert
und
diese krisen enden nicht an
nationalstaatlichen grenzen und genau
deswegen darf unsere antwort darauf
keine rein nationalstaatliche seien im
kampf gegen armut hunger den klimawandel
und die soziale gerechtigkeit brauchen
wir den internationalen schulterschluss
und wir werden endlich eine neue
multilateral und feministische
zusammenarbeit leben und umsetzen
direkt vor der haustür haben es heute
schon häufig gerade erleben wir einen
krieg gegen die ukraine der nicht nur
das leben und die existenzen der
menschen vor ort gefährdet sondern auch
dazu führt dass die zwei kornkammern der
welt die am wichtigsten sind wegfallen
die preise für weizen haben sich in den
letzten wochen noch mal verdoppelt frau
ministerin sie haben es angesprochen
im jemen muss das world food program
seine nahrungsmittelrationen halbieren
andere staaten müssten sich noch weiter
verschulden um brot zu subventionieren
damit ihre bevölkerung sich das
überhaupt leisten kann und wir wissen
dass
nahrungsmittelkrisen zu mehr konflikten
führen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
diese krisen die ich da gerade
aufgezählt habe die hacken zusammen und
sie verstärken sich gegenseitig und
genau deswegen ist es schlichtweg falsch
jetzt den kern beitrag für das
wahlprogramm fast zu halbieren und es
widerspricht
und es widerspricht auch jeglicher logik
den haushaltstitel für die sogenannten
übergangshilfen um 40 prozent zu kürzen
denn gerade das sind die aktivitäten die
dazu führen dass gesellschaft
widerstandsfähig sind gegen die krisen
gegen die belastungen die langen halten
in krisen und ich freue mich sehr genau
darauf im haushaltsverfahren nochmals
ein augenmerk zu legen
brasiliens zu stärken wir kommen gleich
zügen residenz zu stärken bedeutet
nachhaltig sicherheit zu schaffen
sicherheit vor hunger sicherheit vor
vertreibung sicherheit vor armut
sicherheit vor konflikten und sicherheit
vor struktureller gewalt sicherheit
bedeutet eben nicht nur militärische
sicherheit
und deswegen genau deswegen sind wir nun
dafür verantwortlich dass in den
kommenden jahren ist keine schieflage
zwischen den notwendigen ausgaben für
die verteidigung zivile krisenprävention
und einem menschenrechts basierte
entwicklungszusammenarbeit gibt
[Applaus]
wir müssen den menschen in eine
nachhaltige entwicklung und den
klimaschutz investieren und zwar nicht
erst in zehn jahren sondern jetzt und
dauerhaft und es ist gut und richtig und
vor allem notwendig dass wir auch 2022
auf dem kurs liegen für das 0,7 prozent
ziel aber
dieses ziel dürfen uns insbesondere in
den kommenden jahren nicht einfach schön
rechnen
so liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der union ja auch ich bin nicht
zufrieden mit diesem haushalt aber sie
haben wir jetzt schon mal mit ein paar
zahlen rum geworfen und da würde ich
schon darauf hinweisen dass sie sich
vielleicht mal ihren eigenen
regierungsentwurf angucken denen sie uns
noch vorgelegt haben vor ein paar
monaten
denn lieber herr gröhe ja die haben
recht dass im bereich der medien der
haushalt gekürzt wird wir haben den aber
nochmal um fünf millionen erhöht weil
sie wollten nämlich - 15 millionen wir
haben jetzt - 10 millionen gemacht dass
das nicht gutes davon reden wir nicht
aber die letzte
und so zu tun als ob wir das alles
besser machen würden das stimmt
und wir haben auch die ez
partnerschaften für wirtschaft
angesprochen und auch dass wir da haben
wir ein plus im vergleich zu ihrem
regierungsentwurf + + 36 millionen euro
jetzt stellen sie sich hin und
kritisieren dass sie hätten es doch
selber machen kann die letzten 16 jahre
und
der schlechinger sie haben hier über die
sonder initiative zu hunger geredet und
auch wenn ich da hingucker im vergleich
zu ihrem entwurf plus 7 millionen euro
und sie reden hier von glaubwürdigkeit
ich würde sagen wir müssen mal an ihrer
glaubwürdigkeit arbeiten
ihre partei hat sich in den letzten 16
jahren vehement dagegen gewehrt die
globalen krisen anzugehen wir haben
nichts getan für energie unabhängigkeit
jahren nichts getan um die globalen
krisen voranzugehen und
ich da vorne gucken das thema der
das ist so in letzterer gehofft dass wir
gemeinsam
entwicklungspolitik bestreiten die die
globale zukunft wirklich und ich freue
mich auf die bank
die demo war düren war das für die
grünen ja diese haushalt hatte eine
besonderheit
dass der erste haushalt der ampel
koalition ist aber tatsächlich durch das
wahljahr ist der haushalt immer
nachgelagert die beratung und der erste
in suhl für die video des haushalts 2022
der stammt noch von der letzten
bundesregierung und da war die cdu ja
bekanntlich beteiligt
frau präsidentin liebe kollegen es wäre
jetzt eigentlich die chance gewesen
gewesen mal ganz grundsätzlich an die
deutsche entwicklungszusammenarbeit
ranzugehen sich auch die strukturen
anzuschauen und darüber haben wir heute
leider überhaupt gar nichts gehört wir
sehen auch sei der bundesregierung das
gar nicht der anspruch da ist da
irgendetwas zu verändern
ein großes problem der deutschen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit bleibt die
fragmentierung ich hätte eigentlich
gerade von der fdp und vom herr
interimsvorsitzenden hoffmann erwartet
die dass er noch in der letzten
legislatur kritisiert hat dass man sich
da mal ran wagt wie sieht es denn
eigentlich aus wir haben die situation
in deutschland dass ganz viele
ministerien stellen sie doch eine frage
und kreischen sie nicht immer dazwischen
dann können wir uns darüber unterhalten
ganz viele ministerien in deutschland
machen entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
das ist ein kernproblem da war es die
rechte hand nicht was die linke tut und
darum ist auch irgendwie seltsam dass
heute der eindruck erweckt wird als ob
in summe nur elf milliarden euro zur
verfügung gestellt werden die iba summe
die bleibt ungefähr stabil bei den 25
milliarden euro und damit ist
deutschland auch weiterhin einer der
größten geber der welt insbesondere
gemessen an der eigenen bevölkerung
sogar der größte geber der welt und was
hat es gebracht die letzten 50 jahre
nicht viel zwei billionen euro wurden
durch die welt verteilt zwei billionen
euro an entwicklungsleistungen sind
insbesondere in den globalen süden und
auf den afrikanischen kontinent
geflossen und es hat sich so gut wie
nichts verändert wenn wir auf die
letzte legislatur schauen dann hat er
deutschland 84 partner 70 davon gelten
als hochgradig korrupt die länder listen
wurden nicht entsprechend überarbeitet
das ist eine entwicklungszusammenarbeit
die wir seit jahrzehnten betreiben und
gleichzeitig wissen hier in deutschland
die leute nicht mehr wie die rechnungen
bezahlen sollen meine damen und herren
ministerien
bundesländer landkreise die sich um
schwäbische mülltrennung in tunesien
kümmern fahrradwege aus und fort bauen
so sieht es in deutschland aus viele
viele akteure und keiner weiß was der
andere eigentlich tut also anlass für
eine reform hat diese bundesregierung
nicht angepackt die bundesregierung
macht genauso weiter wie die alte
bundesregierung aufgehört hat meine
damen und herren
und man stellt sich da natürlich die
frage für was das geld eigentlich
ausgegeben wird im grunde konnten wir
drei kernbereiche sehen zum einen
erneuerbare energien da gibt es dann so
wunderbare projekte wie deutsch
chinesische zusammenarbeit für
klimafreundlichen verkehr für 7,6
millionen euro
klimafreundliche koch technologie in
kenia und senegal für 30 millionen euro
und die allbekannten led lampen für
marokkanische moscheen für 8,5 millionen
euro das bmz hatte sogar einen leitfaden
entwickelt für grüne moscheen wo mit
religiösen argumenten erklärt wird warum
man jetzt die energiewende braucht und
ganz wichtig ist wurde heute schon
angesprochen die wasserstoff
partnerschaften was haben sie denn
eigentlich
insbesondere jetzt aus diesem konflikt
in der ukraine gelernt sie wollen
lieferanten durch lieferanten
austauschen uns abhängig machen in dem
fall von westafrika das sind instabile
staaten das sind ecowas staaten wie
frankreich auf jeden fall auch noch ein
wörtchen mitzusprechen hat und es wird
dann vor allem interessant wenn man sich
anschaut was eigentlich ihre kaffee dazu
sagt die kaffee sagt dass sie bereit gar
nicht bereit ist diese projekte zu
fördern weil sie schlichtweg nicht
energieeffizient sind meine damen und
herren das ist ein energiepolitischen
irrweg der hier im rahmen der deutschen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit gefördert
wird
und wir haben es heute schon
angesprochen auch mit katar möchte man
jetzt eine wasserstoff partnerschaft
eingehen der bückling hat in katar
erklärt meine damen und herren hier
wurde heute wieder über feministische
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
entwicklungspolitik gesprochen wie sieht
die denn eigentlich aus peitschenhiebe
auf öffentlichen plätzen
sklaven die dort gehalten werden und
frauen die ihren mann fragen müssen wenn
sie ein beschäftigungsverhältnis
eingehen wollen meine damen und herren
das ist offenbar feministische
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
feministische außenpolitik alles ohne
werte doppelmoral da machen wir von der
afg nicht mit
meine damen und herren natürlich dürften
dann die gender projekte nicht fehlen
auch da hat man angekündigt dass man das
intensiver gestalten will großartige
projekte wie angewandt das gender
diversity management im nahen osten
förderung zivilgesellschaftlicher
landesweiter netzwerke in china die
förderung von organisierten
kleinbauernfamilien unter gender
aspekten ungern in uganda das ist
offensichtlich dass womit sich diese
bundesregierung auch beschäftigt meine
damen und herren wenn sie von
subsistenzwirtschaft leben und nicht
wissen wie die familie ernähren wollen
dann ist ihre kleinste sorge dass die
morgens wenn sie aufstehen eine
sorgenfreie wahl aus 84 geschlechter
typen haben
was wollen wir wir wollen ein
ministerium das verantwortlich ist wir
wollen ein evaluierungs institut eine
durch führungsorganisation und eine
entwicklungsbank wir wollen eben diese
fragmentierung beenden wir wollen echte
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
handel und wir müssen vor allem mal über
die bevölkerungsexplosion auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent sprechen darüber
wollen sie nicht sprechen das blenden
sie vollkommen aus aber das ist und
bleibt eine der größten fragen und
herausforderungen unserer zeit
[Applaus]
wenn sie herumgereicht wird dann war
alles richten
der kollege till mansmann kommt jetzt
das wort für die fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben in
der tat am 27 februar eine zeitenwende
erlebt es ist heute schon oft zur
sprache gekommen im kern steht 100
milliarden euro etat für die bundeswehr
und ich stehe aus voller überzeugung
dahinter dass das die richtige
entscheidung war aber es ist auch eine
zeitenwende für andere ressorts für
viele viele ressorts sind betroffen und
in ganz besonderer weise ist das
entwicklungsressort von diesen
veränderungen die jetzt hier eingetreten
sind betroffen und frau ministerin
schulze sie haben in einer sehr
schwierigen zeit dieses ressort
übernommen und sie haben ein sehr kurzer
zeit gezeigt dass sie angemessen klug
reagiert haben hat deshalb gerade in
ihrer rede gesehen dafür danke ich ihnen
ganz ausdrücklich
es ist klar es ist klar dass wir in
vielen punkten jetzt kurzfristig um
steuern müssen vor allen dingen im
bereich humanitärer hilfe ich will dass
sich weiter ausführen das haben viele
kollegen bei dir gemacht aber es geht
auch um mittel und langfristige
strategien
die wir jetzt angehen müssen das
betrifft dann auch die haushaltspläne
die mehr in bewegung sind als sonst und
ich sehe auch in dem derzeitigen entwurf
noch nicht das letzte wort gesprochen
wir sind
wir sind was die sicherheitspolitik an
geht aus einem dornröschenschlaf erwacht
und wir haben vieles jetzt relativ
schnell klar gesehen aber ich habe den
eindruck manche sachen schauen wir noch
etwas verschlafen und das ist
insbesondere im bereich der
energiezusammenarbeit der fall der auch
nachher wird wieder zurück koppelt auch
die sicherheit unseres landes betrifft
ich will ihnen das mal optisch zeigen
die presse ist er immer sehr schnell in
dem aufnehmen von von sachen die jetzt
wichtig sind das ist eine grafik der hat
die wirtschaftswoche vorletzte ausgabe
gebracht sie zeigt die kapazitäten für
grünen wasserstoff im jahr 2050 im jahr
2050 global wo kann man grünen
wasserstoff produzieren und sie sehen
hier zum vergleich dieser fleck hierbei
asien der entspricht etwa der primär ins
primärenergiebedarfs den wir heute haben
sie sehen also es gibt genug gründe
energiewelt weiter was ist ihnen auch
woody ist die ist in den ländern der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit weit weit
überwiegend
und ich spreche jetzt das an was der
kollege babak
energie
zusammenarbeit auf augenhöhe genannt hat
oder auch dass herr kollege dr stedinger
was sie mit viel herzblut vorgetragen
habe ich danke ihnen dafür bei das thema
genau richtig ist nur wir sitzen seit
vier jahren gemeinsam mit dem ausschuss
ich habe es in keinem ihrer haushalte
gesehen
als wäre das thema aus dem himmel
gefallen ist das ist es nicht aber
in der tat wir haben ein bisschen werden
ein bisschen geschlafen diesen
dornröschenschlaf hat 20 jahre gedauert
und jetzt setze ich mich in die zukunft
in 20 jahren 2045 ungefähr wollen wir
energie noch wollen wir klimaneutral
sein bei der energie da gehöre ich lange
diesem haus nicht mehr an das sieht sich
hoffentlich als alter mann in meinem
leben stuhl in heppenheim an der
bergstraße und schaue wahrscheinlich
plenardebatten dann auf einem 3d
fernseher und ich hoffe dass der den
stuhl aus nachhaltiger nationaler
produktion ist die der 3d fernseher
darstellen die patente und die dik der
krebs hinaus europa aus asien
hoffentlich auch aus vielen globalen und
entwicklungsländern aus afrika aber die
energie die weiß ich heute schon um
zumindestens der held aus dem globalen
süden und daran möchten wir uns jetzt
machen und frau ministerin in diesem
sinne freue mich auf diese
zusammenarbeit vielen dank
sagt till mansmann für die fdp fraktion
ist der
entwicklungspolitische sprecher hier der
liberalen und ihm folgt die sprecherin
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung seien
für die spd
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte frau ministerin
als entwicklungspolitische sprecherin
meiner fraktion habe ich hier heute die
unerfreuliche aufgabe erstmals seit
jahren einen reduzierten bmz haushalt zu
debattieren das ist nicht nur
unerfreulich
sondern
das ist meine stärke ehrlich gesagt auch
ein wenig überraschend denn im
koalitionsvertrag haben wir klar
vereinbart dass die mittel für die oder
anrechenbaren ausgaben und die ausgaben
für verteidigung eins zu eins ansteigen
sollen
diese regelung diese regelung folgt aus
unserem gemeinsamen verständnis dass
sicherheit und verteidigung stets im
gleichgewicht mit entwicklungspolitik
und humanitärer hilfe gedacht werden
muss und das ist mir als
sozialdemokraten besonders wichtig wir
sozialdemokratinnen sind in der
diskussion um das zwei prozent ziel
immer mit einem erweiterten
sicherheitsbegriff aufgetreten frieden
schafft man eben nicht nur mit waffen
sondern dem schaffen von
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
perspektiven
denn wenn nun der reguläre
verteidigungsetat um 3,4 milliarden euro
steigen der haushalt des bmz
gleichzeitig um 1,6 milliarden euro
sinken soll wird das den
koalitionsvertrag nicht gerecht das
trifft bei den kolleginnen allach
koalitionsfraktionen auf unverständnis
wie man heute auch hören könnte konnte
wir alle wissen aber auch dass die welt
in der wir heute leben nicht mehr die
welt in der wir den koalitionsvertrag
geschlossen haben putins angriffskrieg
auf die ukraine hat weitreichende
konsequenzen
hat weitreichende konsequenzen
verschiebt unsere perspektiven und
prioritäten das ändert jedoch nichts das
möchte ich ausdrücklich sagen an der
richtigkeit unseres grundsatzes dass wir
verteidigungs und entwicklungspolitik
zusammen denken müssen im gegenteil
dieser grundsatz ist heute relevanter
denn je
denn dieser krieg hat nicht nur
katastrophale auswirkungen auf die
menschen in der ukraine sondern auf
millionen menschen im globalen fügen die
von armut hunger und politischer die
stabilisierung betroffen sind
lassen sie mich lassen sie mich den
durch diesen krieg gesteigerten bedarf
für entwicklungszusammenarbeit an drei
beispielen veranschaulichen erstens
putins angriffskrieg hat unmittelbare
und schwerwiegende folgen für die
menschen in der ukraine
dies erfordert zum einen akute
humanitäre hilfe und die bürokratische
unterstützung von geflüchteten zum
anderen sind sämtliche projekte der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit in den
bereichen bildung zivilgesellschaft und
energie zum erliegen gekommen wir wollen
und müssen nach einem hoffentlich bei
den kriegsende hier unser engagement
verstärken und den wiederaufbau
unterstützen
zweitens wird uns das heute schon
mehrfach genannte thema
ernährungssicherheit in naher zukunft
ganz besonders beschäftigen zwar direkt
vor unserer haustür denn durch putins
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine wird ein
viertel der lieferungen an weizen auf
dem weltmarkt ausfallen das dafür
unweigerlich zu höheren brot preisen
führt die konsequenzen tragen millionen
menschen die bereits heute vom hunger
bedroht sind oder gar schon von ja da
schon unter hunger leiden diese ausfälle
und preissteigerung bergen drittens die
gefahr politischer destabilisierung
gerade in der männer regierung vom
libanon bis marak osterbrot preis ein
politischer preis höhere preise für
lebensmittel
gerade in ohnehin schon fragilen
kontexten führen unweigerlich zu einer
destabilisierung
das wissen wir aus erfahrung damit diese
dynamik gar nicht erst entsteht müssen
wir jetzt entgegenwirken und dazu
brauchen wir geld und dafür sorgt wird
es ein erweiterungs haushalt geben die
wir heute auch schon gehört haben ich
hoffe liebe liebe cdu csu fraktion dass
sie dafür genauso enthusiastisch kämpfen
wie heute
ich hasse kurz zusammen
entwicklungspolitik schafft perspektiven
schafft zukunft schafft ein
selbstbestimmtes leben in würde und
schafft somit letztendlich stabilität
und frieden lassen sie uns außerdem
nicht vergessen dass neben dem
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine der in
diesen tagen im zentrum unserer
aufmerksamkeit steht noch zahlreiche
weitere kriege und krisen auf unserer
welt anhalten seit jahren leiden und
sterben menschen in afghanistan jemen
süd sudan äthiopien
syrien mia wir dürfen die seit jahren
unter diesen konflikten leiden menschen
nicht vergessen auch sie verdienen
unsere solidarität und unterstützung
dazu haben wir uns verpflichtet
das alles vor dem hintergrund der korona
pandemie die pandemie macht
jahrzehntelange entwicklungsfortschritte
rückgängig wir sind noch lange nicht
fertig mit dem auf und ausbau von
funktionierenden basis gesundheitssystem
wir sind noch lange nicht fertig mit dem
wiederaufbau zusammengebrochenen
globaler lieferketten
wir sind noch lange nicht fertig mit dem
mit dem wiederherstellen der
dazugehörigen arbeitsplätze das alles
liegt noch vor uns
entwicklungspolitik ist strukturpolitik
sie brauchte langfristiges denken und
eine verlässliche planung unserer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit muss für
unsere partner wieder berechenbar
zielorientiert und nachhaltig wirksam
sein dazu bedarf es finanziell
abgesicherte programme und zwar
langfristig
wir sind mit der koalition angetreten um
mehr fortschritt zu wagen was ist ein
bündnis für freiheit gerechtigkeit und
nachhaltigkeit wert ohne eine
ausreichende finanzierte
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die
fortschritte auch auf internationaler
ebene ermöglicht ich bin zuversichtlich
dass wir im laufe der parlamentarischen
beratung eine lösung finden werden um
unserer verantwortung gerecht zu werden
danke
sagte sonne ab die hier für die spd
fraktion ja einem koalitionsvertrag
tatsächlich da sind ja die
entwicklungsausgaben mit den
verteidigungsausgaben eigentlich
gekoppelt steigen die
verteidigungsausgaben sollen eigentlich
in gleicher weise entwicklungsausgaben
steigen aber angesichts des 100
milliarden euro sondervermögens für die
verteidigung für die bundeswehr glaubt
kaum ein
optimistischer entwicklungspolitiker
wohl an diesen aufwuchs
später stunde des mittwochnachmittag
sind wir jetzt zeugen einer sehr
lebhaften und emotional geführten
debatte geworden wobei die ampel
wirklich ein skurriles schauspiel
abgeliefert verehrte frau ministerin mit
ihrem ein leitungs vortrag haben sie mit
blumigen und möglichst unbestimmten
formulierungen versucht diese klatsche
des finanzministers im regierungsentwurf
zu entschuldigen beziehungsweise davon
abzulenken und dann so gerade noch auf
der zielgerade den eindruck zu erzeugen
dass mit dem ergänzungs haushalt aus dem
grund des verheerenden krieges in der
ukraine eine korrektur geschaffen werden
würde ein untauglicher versuch und der
ist natürlich vor allen dingen um so
kritikwürdige als sie noch ende dezember
in ihrem ersten interview nach
amtsantritt massiv mit ihrem
amtsvorgänger ins gericht gegangen sind
und ihm nicht nachhaltig und vollkommen
und zuletzt unzulängliche finanzpolitik
vorgehalten haben
das schauspiel nimmt dann seine
fortsetzung mit den redebeiträgen der
vertreter der ampel koalition ist es
schon bemerkenswert dass aber auch
wirklich kein einziger kein einziger die
zufriedenheit mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf auch nur andeuten
konnte im gegenteil unisono waren alle
der meinung dass der vorgelegte
regierungsentwurf überhaupt nicht den
aktuellen anforderungen mit oder ohne
die auswirkungen der ukraine krise
gerecht werden könnte aber um die diese
peinlichkeit natürlich nicht in die
öffentlichkeit zu tragen wird darauf
verwiesen dass der vorherige
regierungsentwurf noch in der endphase
der großen koalition
noch unzulänglich gewesen sein soll und
auch da wird wiederum ein historisch
präziser gesichtspunkt außen vor
gelassen auch dieser trug die
handschrift eines finanzministers des
jetzigen kanzlers olaf scholz
finanzminister olaf scholz der aus einer
grundlegenden abneigung gegenüber dem
arbeitsbereich der entwicklungspolitik
dem erfolgreichen entwicklungsminister
gerd müller in der endphase noch einen
delle verpassen wollte auch das ein
unglaubliches unterfangen von der wahren
eigentlichen verantwortung abzulenken
und um es noch mal an dieser stelle ganz
klar hervorzuheben seit
2014 hat sich das haushaltsvolumen von 6
4 milliarden euro auf 12,4 milliarden
euro fast verdoppelt das ergebnis
hartnäckige
erfolgreicher und vor allen dingen
überzeugender
haushaltspolitik eines guten
entwicklungshilfeministers gerd müller
liebe frau
kollegin ab die sie haben
dankenswerterweise in der tat auf den
koalitionsvertrag hingewiesen seite
119 beinhaltet diesen dank denkwürdigen
satz dass die entwicklungsausgaben im
verhältnis von eins zu eins wie ebenso
wie die verteidigungsausgaben steigen
sollten sie haben aber eben die
diskrepanz die jetzt eingetreten ist
versucht damit zu erklären dass die
veränderung der welt lage eingetreten
ist und sich daraus dann auch eine
veränderung der betrachtung ergeben
müsste da muss ich ihnen in aller
deutlichkeit
widersprechen nämlich gerade die jetzt
eingetretene veränderungen der weltlage
hätte zur folge dass mindestens das
verhältnis von eins zu eins hätte
eingehalten werden müssen denn die
auswirkungen des ukraine krieges die
auswirkungen des ukraine krieges werden
in bartender geschwindigkeit die
lebensverhältnisse der menschen im
globalen süden beeinträchtigen und
deshalb müssen wir neben allen hilfen
die wir in den nächsten wochen monaten
und vielleicht jahren für die menschen
in der ukraine aufbringen müssen mit
sofortiger wirkung unserer
entwicklungspolitischen aktivitäten im
globalen süden fortsetzen und deshalb
halten sie sich an ihren
koalitionsvertrag dann können sie
vielleicht noch etwas retten und zum
guten schluss
verehrte kollegin thüringen die kritik
keinerlei maßnahmen gegen globale krisen
seit über vier jahren arbeiten wir
tatkräftig im rahmen der globalen
gesundheit an den entsprechenden
gesundheits herausforderungen die auf
der ganzen welt existieren und auch an
dieser stelle scheitert der
regierungsentwurf weil die entsprechende
verpflichtungsermächtigung zugunsten des
gfg m des globalen fonds gegen aids
malaria und tuberkulose massiv
gestrichen worden ist wir haben in
unserer internationalen aktivitäten
in diesem jahr sechs auf grenzen die
sich mit globalen gesundheits
herausforderungen beschäftigen und in
allen diesen bereichen gibt es leider
keinen signifikanten
aufwuchs erliegen an dieser stelle
blamieren und deshalb ist es einfach nur
konsequent aber reichen herzens dass wir
diesem regierungsentwurf unter kleinen
zustimmen können vielleicht zu lang und
mit der rede von georg kippels da geht
auch die beratung hierzu diesem
einzuplanen so langsam zu ende